[Music]
you're on wrestlemania and uh this was
uh you used uh some stunning moves do
you mind if we show a clip right now
from wrestlemania and then we'll analyze
yes
maria menounos co-host of extra part of
dancing with the stars this season
[Music]
[Applause]
that's a
double
that is an incredible movie i've never
i've watched wrestling
i've watched wrestling a long time i've
never seen that move used before yeah
it's called the stink face
and the worst part was okay so get this
so i'm in white
hands and you have to do it and of
course like i'm i'm stink facing her
makeup got all over my pants and it was
all over twitter the next day or hours
later that they thought i had messed
myself up
and i was like oh this is not going down
because normally you just don't respond
to something like that but i'm like
there's no way i'm gonna let people
think i poop to my fans anyway so i
tweeted out i was like um people that's
makeup don't get cray-cray on me
i think you solved it with the whole
don't get cray-cray
it's gonna be used in presidential
debates